ta paix prépare la guerre un adage
visiblement oublié qui n'a pas porté ses
fruits pour le gouvernement français
dans la gestion de cette crise sanitaire
et quand on parle de défense on parle
surtout de matériel médical remontons au
début des années 2000 le gouvernement en
place privilégiée la manufacture
étrangères pour se fournir et ce malgré
les avertissements lancés sur les
risques croissants de pandémie mondiale
au contraire de l'allemagne la france
devient alors dépendante des usines
étrangères conséquences emmanuel macron
s'est retrouvé au pied du mur et n'a pas
pu augmenter la production nationale de
masques de tests de ventilateurs et même
de paracétamol
les français ont été contraints de se
rationner et pourtant quand on met le
chef de l'état devant le fait accompli
il continue denis ayons collectivement
l'honnêteté de dire qu'au début de mois
de mars et encore plus en février ou en
janvier personne ne parlait des masques
parce que nous n'aurions jamais pensé
être obligés de restreindre la
distribution de ceux ci pour les
soignants il y a eu une doctrine
restrictives pour ne jamais être en
rupture de masques il y a eu ensuite un
approvisionnement une production
renforcée et nous n'avons jamais été en
rupture
ce qui est vrai c'est qu'il y ait eu des
manques détention la transparence est
essentiellement ça qui a manqué à
emmanuel macron mais les faits sont
têtus et les new york times vise juste
en parlant de manque de matériel de
protection
le 21 avril dernier selon une enquête
publiée par un syndicat de médecins
anesthésistes 20 % des médecins disaient
manquait encore de masques de type ffp2
et 25% d'entre eux de lunettes de
protection
du côté de l'opposition on s'insurge du
déni présidentielle je pense que le
gouvernement aurait dû dire dès le début
de la crise écoutez on ne s'est pas bien
préparé pour des raisons que nous
éclairciront on est obligés de réserver
les masques soignants ça va être dur
mais on va y arriver il y aurait eu ce
discours de vérité les choses auraient
été plus facile pour le président comme
pour la majorité
force est de constater que la france
n'était pas du tout préparé à faire face
à une telle pandémie est même
aujourd'hui le gouvernement n'a aucune
garantie qu'il pourra assurer un
approvisionnement suffisant dans les
semaines à venir pour se protéger contre
une éventuelle seconde vague du virus
pourtant la france a longtemps identifié
les masses et le matériel médical
des biens de défense nationale
indispensable en cas de pandémie
et puis on s'est rendu compte que
produire et stocker des milliards de
masques coûter cher
donc on a cessé de les stocker durant
ces dix dernières années et par la même
occasion la production nationale s'est
effondré au même moment où l'industrie
pharmaceutique du pays s'installe et
également à l'étranger la france avait
décidé qu'il n'était plus nécessaire de
maintenir des stocks massifs dans le
pays
étant donné que les usines de production
pouvait être opérationnel très
rapidement notamment en chine
sauf que la chine berceau de l'épidémie
a été submergé par les commandes la
chaîne d'approvisionnement mondialisée
s'est donc rapidement effondré
le ministère de la santé a donc perdu un
temps précieux trop précieux puisque
plus de 28000 personnes sont mortes
ducobu 19 en france
la france qui possède l'un des taux de
mortalité dieu couronne à virus les plus
élevés au monde
tout cela pointe un problème celui de la
capacité industrielle du pays
nos voisins allemands ont beaucoup mieux
géré la crise puisqu'il avait cette
capacité de fabriquer en masse des tests
et du matériel médical
la france c'est trop désindustrialisé
depuis les années 2000 elle en paie le
prix aujourd'hui en s'assurant un
fournisseur national
la france aurait donc pu éviter d'être
exclusivement dépendante d'importations
mais la plupart des usines de masques
ont fermé leurs portes comme la plainte
elle avec qui le gouvernement avait un
contrat d'exclusivité permet en 2018 car
la politique de stockage des masques et
de médicaments étaient considérés comme
du gaspillage budgétaire en à peine dix
ans avec la destruction des masques est
périmé le stock national français est
passée de 1,7 milliard en 2009 à 150
millions en mars 2020 des chiffres qui
montrent à quel point la france a
sacrifié le secteur de la santé sur
l'autel de l'économie néolibérale une
stratégie qui au final a coûté beaucoup
plus cher que prévu